i i will say specifically tremaine and
knoxville
saved my life by
enforcing
some some consequences like if somebody
doesn't they made me want to jump off
the tallest building on the planet
okay be careful with seeing things like
that because that triggers
5150s and saying i want to i said
that's why i got in my position because
i said
well i said if i don't see my kid if
he's not on that airplane
then i'm going to jump off a bridge or
something right and then i got
march-made acted in florida which means
you have to do 90 days or something and
i said have you ever seen my movies i
jump off of so many bridges in the
bushes and pools you [ __ ] idiots i
didn't mean i was gonna kill myself
right so
i did madero beach on the on the west
side and i made it 75 days i had 15 days
left and they're like bam you've been
rocking the same sweatpants for 75 days
i'll be like yeah i'm not trying to get
any [ __ ] [ __ ] around here i don't
give a [ __ ] and like well you're getting
kicked out for bad hygiene i'm like oh
my god so i get to another place in
ocala national forest so i'm like so
this is day 76 they're like oh no you're
starting to square one i'm like
[ __ ] so i make it to day 80
there and i smoke a cigarette and i
throw it out and it's smoking in a bush
and they film it they're like you could
have lit the whole national forest on
fire you're getting sent to west palm
beach
now i know i'm getting back to square
one that's why i've been doing this [ __ ]
for a year okay
and i did 111 days there and i wanted to
get transferred to florida because it
was just a better option until i figured
out that the marksman act only happens
in florida
okay now that concerns me about i mean
by the way the stories are hilarious
getting kicked out for bad hygiene and
for trying to light a forest on fire
both very funny anecdotes but the the
what concerns me about that is that you
describe it as oh and that sent me back
to square one the clock and so i had to
start over
and it was longer before i could be done
you know and i i would just want to
impress upon you that it's not about a
beginning and an end it's about
learning a new way to live and and that
new way to live is really it's important
that that we don't blame everything on
everybody else and and
assume that no i know but i already knew
i already knew in arizona that i wanted
to
end it and be over with with alcohol
but i had to finish my time
and and i just it just sucks that i had
10 more days left and i was done
but i got transferred and i had to do 90
again and then transferred to 90 years
like this is going to end so now it
finally ended
now um yes but but now i have to just do
outpatient treatment in florida until
july 17th then i'm going to move to
southern california and and just do iop
which is just
classes three days a week okay good and
when and when
you uh
come to california
like
aside from the classes
iop see when that ends like once all the
treatment is done like what's your plan
for protecting your sobriety
just go to meetings hang out with sober
people get a sponsor maybe conrad i
really liked him at scheckler's place
i love it yeah i love it i mean dude
like uh that's the first time that
you've ever
said anything that sounded like you you
had some willingness to to join the team
and and it's borderline inappropriate
and my phone is just
programmed with a very select few of
just sober people i love it like nobody
else it's just all sober friends or
family i love it and i don't let anybody
else in there's nothing that i won't do
or novak like any of our sober buddies
there's nothing we won't do to help you
stay sober yeah
yeah i found myself really a lot more
productive i would let days go by
without answering important people which
probably [ __ ] up a lot of business
deals like this [ __ ] hasn't answered
for a week let's let's just do the
clothing line with somebody else or
whatever you know
right it's called stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and if you go on amazon
and type in stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on amazon and buy
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude